some of the president's supporters
accused Chief Justice John Roberts of
playing political games after a Supreme
Court ruling supporting abortion rights
Roberts joined four liberal justices to
strike down a Louisiana law that had
restricted abortion providers Robert
said the law was too similar to a Texas
law that the court threw out four years
ago Jan Crawford is at the Supreme Court
for us Jan good morning why is this case
so significant Tony I mean it was the
first major test of abortion rights
since President Trump added two new
conservative justices to the Supreme
Court but it was another conservative
Chief Justice John Roberts
who cast the deciding vote with liberals
the first time in his career he's voted
to strike down an abortion regulation
the justices struck down a law that
could have left Louisiana with one
abortion provider this clinic in the
northern part of the state sued to stay
open after Louisiana's unsafe abortion
Protection Act mandated doctors who
perform abortions must maintain
admitting privileges at a nearby
hospital a restriction the clinic's
director called devastating not just for
the people in our area but statewide and
I think there would be national
repercussions as well just as Stephen
Breyer writing for the courts for
liberal justices called the Louisiana
law an undue burden that offers no
significant health related benefits
Chief Justice John Roberts objected more
narrowly arguing the law Roe precedent
nominated by george w bush roberts has
disappointed conservatives joining the
courts for liberal justices on landmark
rulings that upheld the Affordable Care
Act and rejected the Trump
administration's efforts to add a
citizenship question to the census two
weeks ago Roberts voted to expand LGBTQ
rights in the workplace and protect
young undocumented immigrants called
dreamers leaving conservative court
watchers like Ilya Shapiro wondering I
don't think that he's moving left I
think he's just as conservative as he
ever was but given that he is now
definitively the middle of the court the
the swing seat or at least the median
vote he is acting strategically and he
wants the court not
to be perceived as Republicans and
Democrats or liberals and conservatives
now the Supreme Court is about to weigh
in on another politically charged case
in this election year whether Congress
can subpoena president Trump's tax
returns decision and that case could
come as soon as this week Gail that's a
big case a lot of people watching that
thank you very much Jann